foreign
and six years ago I received information
that changed the course of the rest
of my life
from 1969 through 2001 the US government
murdered over 12 billion birds in the
American Skies
they did this using poisonous toxins
dropped from airplanes it was contagious
and murdered all of the birds over the
course of about 40 years
now I know this is not the public
understanding of this and may sound
absurd but please just bear with me keep
an open mind and just be respectful
please as I share this information with
you I know a lot of you may be wondering
why would the government kill 12 billion
Birds it seems like an awful lot of
trouble for a government to go through
the reason is as devastating as it is
simple for each bird the government
killed they replaced it with a
surveillance drone replica in Disguise
designed to spy on the American people
now
some may say if you're the government at
least that this is a worthy sacrifice
these 12 billion lives for the safety of
the people right
I don't know about that it seems like a
pretty serious limit on our freedom
wouldn't you agree
proof that birds are robots is all
around us if you start looking for
starters uh Birds charge their batteries
on power lines
so they can refuel up high and they can
watch the civilians you know
they also track civilians using a liquid
tracking device
you ever wonder why birds poop on your
car
do you need more evidence I can really I
can go all day up here uh who here has
seen a baby pigeon
you haven't have you it's weird there's
all these adult pigeons where all the
babies
uh
they come out of the factory as adults
so
there's no organic growth you know uh
it's a Smoking Gun
over the years as I began putting this
information together
I began realizing the extent of all this
there were times I wished I never even
learned this my life would be so much
easier you know I remember before I I
knew this information I was happier My
Little Steps were lighter you know but I
always come back to this it is my moral
obligation as one of the few privileged
enough to know this to share it with you
the blind sheep you know
and that's what I've been doing for
years now
I'm a part of a movement called Birds
aren't real
and in 2021 I was promoted to public
information officer for the movement
it's the honor of my life
I had one job no thank you thank you
um
thank you
my one job was to deprogram the public
from the bird lie and deprogram is a
very specific word because you all are
programmed you know that right we live
in a pro-bird civilization drenched in
propaganda for instance every state has
a state bird the national mascot is a
bald eagle presidents don't talk they
tweet then the tweets are covered on the
bird logo media
once I knew this my first order of
business was to get the information out
to the American people get off the
internet into the real world so that's
what I did I bought a van covered in
decals with facts I wanted to turn the
highway into an information Highway
awaken the people I went City to City
holding rallies meeting up with our
thousands of supporters growing by the
day and I was putting up Billboards
wherever we went sharing our simple but
powerful message look at how beautiful
it is
now the governments the government did
take note of what we were doing and they
sent some Intimidators to try and deter
us from our mission you can see them
right uh right there
um but
we did not fold we kept on going we
started holding rallies at some of the
most evil Pro bird corporations in the
world starting with Twitter where we
brought hundreds out to protest their
Pro bird logo months later we brought
500 people out to CNN headquarters to
demand fairer coverage for bird truthers
on air then just last year we brought 2
000 people out to Washington Square in
New York City to demand that the mayor
shut down every pigeon in the city
here's what that looks like
[Applause]
I can't even tell you how that felt I
took that video Standing on the top of
the van megaphone in hands knowing we
were Awakening a country that needs it
so badly
can't think of anything more beautiful
okay let me start this talk over uh I do
not actually believe that birds are
robots
and everyone else in this picture is
also in on the bit
this is a character that I played for
four years the leader of a fake movement
with fake evidence and a fake history
our goal was to convince the public that
our satirical movement was a real one
and see if the media would believe what
we were saying
to do this I played this character that
I just showed you we held rallies put up
Billboards we even sent the media a lot
of fake evidence we hired an old actor
to posed as an ex-cia agent confessing
to his crimes uh we sent them a historic
email leak called poultry gate that came
out of the Pentagon
where we forged hundreds of fake emails
exposing Elites and government officials
in the in the bird drone surveillance
plot
it didn't take much to convince the
media uh after just one summer holding
rallies like this it became nationally
syndicated news on tons of local news
stations that we were a real movement
that had been around for 50 years
and there was a there was a Resurgence
happening where it was coming back and
there was a radical new leader myself uh
bringing the movement back as the rise
of conspiracy theories swept the nation
at this point I'm sitting on my couch
watching the media report on my fake
movement as a real one and third is
probably time to come out of character
one because we'd accomplished what we
came there to do uh but also I didn't
want this to snowball in anything it was
never supposed to so in 2021 I broke
character revealed the movement was a
farce on the front page of the New York
Times and I was very proud as you can
see allow me to reintroduce myself one
more time uh hi I'm Peter can you say hi
Peter
oh I'd like to tell you a little bit
about myself I grew up in Arkansas in
Little Rock
where I was homeschooled on the
outskirts of town
the community that I grew up with was
hyper conservative and religious
and almost everyone that I knew believed
in some form of conspiracy theory
whether it was that Obama was the
Antichrist or that there are microchips
in the vaccines
during my entire life I always felt like
I was on the fringes of normal society
uh so as you can imagine when it became
time for me to play a character
the conspiracy theorist was a pretty
easy one for me to tap into
the years in character I used the same
Cadence logic and arguments as those I
grew I grew up around just with a
different Theory swap them I was really
dedicated to playing this character as
convincingly as I could as method as
possible so I spent days sometimes in
character a lot of time out in public
with the van there just talking with
strangers it led to hundreds of
interactions with strangers who thought
that I was a real conspiracy theorist
I'd often be out there cowboy hat on
handing out flyers that said things like
uh like if it flies it spies
um
we had another flyer that said bird
watching goes both ways
and during these times as I'm handing
out flyers and talking with people
there were hundreds maybe thousands of
instances over the years where strangers
would approach me you know they'd see me
in public and I'd see them notice me
and walk up to me with complete disdain
on their face
they thought that I was a real
conspiracy theorist
and time and time again they'd come up
to me look me right in the eyes just as
close as I am to you right here and uh
it would tell me how stupid I am
they told me I was uneducated
that I was crazy
that I was the problem with this country
when this happens I didn't feel the
emotions of the character
that I thought I would
my out of character self May interpret
these interactions as a funny response
to someone that fell for the comedy
project but instead I felt the emotions
of the character
I felt emboldened and
I felt sad and angry
like they didn't even take the time to
know me uh they instantly condemned me
judged me
and othered me
I'd found myself on the opposite side of
this equation that I'd grown up around
the normal
and The Fringe
and in those moments when those people
were talking to me they could not have
been more ineffective at what I would
assume they really want
less conspiracy theorists in the world
these experiences hundreds of them over
the years watching how people interact
with those in the fringes of our society
gave me an entirely New Perspective on
our approach to conspiracy theorists
whether it's how we frame them in the
conventional media to how we deal with
those in our own lives
if our goal is to live in a shared
reality with our neighbors
what if our current approach isn't
bringing us any closer to that what if
by talking to conspiracy theorists like
their ignorance and stupid we're
actually pushing them farther away from
the truth that we want them to see
because what happens when someone tells
you that you're stupid you're all wrong
you're the problem
you'll feel judged and dismissed and
most importantly you'll feel othered
which may lead you to look for safety in
those who are like-minded
to do what they have been doing for you
affirm your selfhood give you a sense of
identity belonging
these are some of the most basic human
desires
we have to consider that conspiracy
theorists are not just joining these
groups for no reason
they're getting rewards out of these
things that we are all looking for
a sense of purpose community
I grew up with the internet
and during my time with this project
especially out of character people have
talked to me about the misinformation
age and just you know terrifying problem
of online Echo Chambers and conspiracy
theorists but
I want to remind us that there are
humans behind a lot of these screens uh
it's not not just numbers
everyone's unique experience influences
their own narrative about the world
there's no blueprint for how to deal
with this yet but I do not think that
online Echo Chambers a conspiracy
theorists or this inevitable symptom of
Life online the internet is about 30
years old and things are changing
quickly and I think it'll be very
important that we develop new solutions
for these new problems
on a fundamental level
what if by addressing belief before
belonging
we're starting the conversation at the
wrong place
instead of sitting in Collective
bewilderment and frustration about how
these people could believe these things
these crazies what if we first looked
under the hood and thought about what
made them vulnerable to this information
in the first place what might they be
getting out of this they're not getting
in their everyday lives
how much does it have to do with a
different truth
or how much does it have to do with the
community that that truth brings
we need to think about people's
circumstances and reference points to
see them as fellow human beings who want
to believe in something and want to
belong just like all of us do in this
room because if we continue with our
current approach of arguing on the level
of belief
it's not going to get us anywhere
going to end up with more Echo Chambers
more disinformation and more
polarization
instead we can do the harder work of
looking into what is fueling the need
for an alternate truth
Not only would this lend us more empathy
for those who think differently than us
but I really think this might be the
only actually productive means
productive means
of moving toward the shared reality that
we all want to live in let's direct our
energy toward the crisis of belonging
and then maybe we will understand the
crisis of belief
before I go I'll leave with one more
word just don't forget
if it flies it's fine thank you
so much
okay